let me say something about Tombstone now
because I get so so eff and tired of
people ask me if Kurt Russell directed
the movie okay Kurt Russell did not
direct the movie okay Kurt Russell was
responsible for getting the movie off
the ground I never would have played
Johnny Ringo if it wasn't for Kurt
Russell and I told you last time I was
here I love Kurt Russell and he's a
great great person and I and I and a
great movie star um he's a movie star
who handles it really well you know uh
but he's he didn't direct the movie no
it was directed uh by kind of a a
committee you know we talked about
George cosmatos who came in to replace
Kevin jar so Kevin jar shoots five weeks
they throw all that stuff away and then
um uh George M George kados takes over
and he's kind of a visual guy and we
shoot for another month or two six weeks
or something like that and then they
then they then then they they go into
post and when you go into post you you
know you edit the movie it was edited by
a good good editor but uh I know that
Kurt immediately right after that movie
went on to do a movie called Stargate
that they made the television series out
of right so they they did Stargate and
he because I went to visit him on the
set like a week after we wrapped the
movie and he was already doing Stargate
but watch him and anybody watch Kurt
Russell in in Stargate and he's so
grumpy and angry fromst the residual
effect I you know that's the way that I
you know when I saw the movie I thought
like I've never seen him so grumpy
before you know did you not remember him
being grumpy on the set of toown oh he
was no he was never on no no he's fun he
was like like I said he's got a great
laugh he has a lot of fun uh but what I
was saying to you before is like him in
Val kind of bonded so it was him and Val
that they kind of used to hang out too
so you know that that happens on movies
um but you said he didn't direct it he
didn't direct it was directed by
committee I mean it was a great so
everybody had a hand and like vision and
stuff everybody had a hand in it but you
know a lot of the stuff got cut out of
the movie uh before we got a chance to
shoot it well here it is I'll be able to
find it now oh I like the glasses well
you know I got I had some started having
some problems well
you're with my eyes no but not looking
just like pain and uh yeah I went to my
uh I went to my doctor and he sent me to
an ey guy and the guy said like he
looked at me and did all the test and
everything he oh you got the Johnny Depp
disease I was like you're too
good-looking no he just said you got the
Johnny Depp disease you got to wear
sungrass glasses the rest of your life
I'm like oh oh do really do I have have
to he's like y i and that's that's what
I yeah I don't even know Johnny Depp had
a disease reester or sunglasses all the
time what's it called I believe so the
Johnny Depp disease that's what my
that's my the jdds that's what my doctor
called I'm going to I'm going to say I
have a Michael Bean disease I'm going to
start wearing [__]
sunglasses you know you wear sunglasses
at night so any time you get recognized
anymore if I wear sunglasses at night he
must be a movie star or he's Cory Hart I
wear my son glasses at night I know that
you that you saw the movie a long time
ago but for people who know that movie
well um
uh I'm just [__] around about the
glasses that wasn't true no are you
kidding me no so you don't have a Johnny
Depp disease there's no such thing
actually I believed it didn't you Ryan
actually [__] you